[Music]
when you hear that someone is living in
gratitude
immediately we start to think of them as
a monk sitting on the top of a high
mountain
to say we need to live in gratitude
sounds like hippie dippy ooey gooey
stuff
but that's exactly how omar brownson
lives his life
and he is not a monk he's a businessman
and an urban planner and he's into all
kinds of cool projects with architects
like frank gehry
but he learned the hard way that his
high stress life
was hurting him
and hurting his family and gratitude was
the solution he found
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
omar branson before we start an episode
about gratitude i think it's probably
important that i start by asking you
what are you grateful for right now what
i always come to is just this moment
being able to
take a breath pause
and just notice that there's so much to
be grateful for whether this moment with
you getting to meet you the spontaneity
and
yeah i'm i'm overwhelmed
when somebody says do you have a
gratitude practice
you know it sounds a little hippy-dippy
to a lot of people and i think if we
just change the words instead of saying
do you have a gratitude practice
simply ask the question
what are you grateful for
the thing that i've taken away since
i've met you
is to ask myself that question when i'm
feeling good that's obvious i think we
all sort of feel gratitude we're in a
good space you know my god i love you
you're the best but i think what i've
taken away from you since i've met you
is
the ability to say what am i grateful
for in times when i'm struggling in
times when i'm not feeling my best is
that part of a gratitude practice is
that
like what does gratitude practice mean
well i think that's absolutely the time
when gratitude counts i think as you
said anybody can be grateful for when
times are good and things
are going your way the wind is behind
your back
it's when you're facing the headwinds
that i think the gratitude really kicks
in and the power of it
um
[Music]
because it's you know the brain
has a biological bias to see the
negative and so
learning to not be reactive to the brain
and just being like okay wait a second
is this actually reality or
am i falling into some bad habits here
how did you discover gratitude so about
seven years ago
i was
leading uh the large sort of scale
transformation of the l.a river
and
yes la has a river not everybody knew i
didn't know when i first started that we
had a river when i first saw it i
thought it was like a
sewage thing yeah concrete channel that
was in terminator you know great great
chase scenes with uh schwarzenegger
actually it's 300 million gallons of
water that goes down the river today all
to say
it's 51 miles a million people live
within a mile of the river it's
to me an opportunity to reimagine
la the second largest city in america
with green infrastructure right like how
do we bring nature and culture together
um we were working with uh
the architect frank gehry and so it was
high profile lots of attention if
there's a million people there's three
million opinions
and i was stressed out um as the
founding executive director and i
received a fellowship to go
travel and i told the foundation that i
wanted to do a silent retreat uh to
begin that fellowship so i spent six
days up in big sur
and in all that silence i just realized
how impatient of a human being i am
and
at the end of six days i got to talk to
this monk about it
and he said omar the root word in latin
for impatience is patis
which means to suffer
he said that's your burden to carry
and i was like i don't i don't really
want that burden and so how do i
sort of do something differently so i
tried meditation i tried mindfulness
but it was ultimately the practice of
gratitude that helped me learn to pause
and just not
feel that energy of like why isn't
things moving fast enough the obvious
solution to
impatience is to be patient
to learn patience right yeah and that
didn't work for you the sort of
meditative mindful
take a deep breath didn't work and what
helped you overcome the suffering
of impatience
was to discover gratitude yeah i mean
and i think that part of it is
meditation and mindfulness can be very
head-oriented
gratitude is something you actually feel
in your heart it's an emotion and so i
think part of the challenge is that i
was already kind of very logical very
rational and that sort of logic rational
brain was trying to control everything
my fear came up around
how do i control everything that i don't
know that uncertainty that unknown and a
large-scale project that's thinking
about the next 20 30 years of los
angeles there's a lot of moving pieces
and at some point realizing like how do
i let things go
and
be more present that's actually an
emotion not sort of a way that the brain
can think why is it that gratitude is
the thing that helps you let go of that
it seems incongruous
i think part of it is
learning to actually feel your emotions
without becoming your emotions so when
you're very kind of logic you're like
you can rationalize your feelings you
can rationalize
your emotions
as opposed to feel them
and when you feel them then you can
actually let them go and so you're like
oh look there's fear oh look there's
anger as soon as you're able to i i like
to think of it as noticing and name
something
so often what we do is we maybe notice
what we're feeling but oftentimes we
don't name it
but by noticing in the naming then all
of a sudden it doesn't have sort of the
same power um over us it's sort of like
the fear of fear is greater than the
fear itself i learned this recently from
sarah kubrick the millennial therapist
how we don't do a good job of labeling
our emotions you know when you ask me
how do you feel it's usually good bad
angry happy sad that's about it you know
and emotions are more complex i always
thought like emotions were like wild
beasts i imagine horses trampling
through the prairie and and i know that
like
you know i've gone to good schools
because i've studied hard i've ran and
played sports because i could train my
body
i never knew that i could actually train
my emotions i just thought you were born
with an amazing disposition and cool
calm and collective or you weren't
it's not something that we teach and
this is i think what's beautiful is that
my daughters actually have social
emotional learning in their schools so
they actually are learning mindfulness
and meditation and gratitude those were
not skills at all that we even talked
about i think you say it incredibly well
that it's not about soft skills it's
about human skills yeah i i hate the
term soft skills you know in work they
always talk about hard skills and soft
skills well heart and soft are opposites
and i would hate to think that the
skills of being a good human being are
the opposite of being a good worker
it proposes that we should suppress any
humanity at work and so i i like to call
them human skills and i want to be good
at my hard skills and i want to be good
at my human skills and that makes me you
know better whatever i'm doing when you
ask what human skills were i would have
said listening effective confrontation
conflict resolution how to give and
receive feedback these are the standard
list of things i offer when somebody
says what are human skills and i've just
recently added gratitude the skill of
gratitude i think is a human skill that
we don't practice in some ways instead
of i'd say hard skills and human skills
one way i would think about it is
technical skills versus adaptive skills
and technical skills sort of are allow
us to solve specific problems but often
those problems
tend to be very linear and narrow i
would say adaptive skills are the ones
like how do we actually deal with the
messiness of humanity right and this is
a concept that i've been playing with is
like if gratitude makes visible what we
value
fearless gratitude
is what enables us to see
what we take for granted and maybe make
invisible and so when we can learn to
kind of see what we make visible and to
actually see what we make invisible or
take for granted
then we're actually really i think in a
place
to be more present to all the challenges
that life presents
let me say it back to be clear that i
understand
gratitude is acknowledging
the scene the understood
the present
fearlessness is acknowledging the unseen
the hard or impossible to understand
and
the unknown future
and that's that combination
of being immensely grateful for what i
have that makes me stronger as i go into
the unknown
and more accepting that i cannot control
it but rather i will find gratitude on
each step of the path yeah so if i think
about the unfolding of my own movement
in my own career my own ambitions things
go wrong all the time
yes
and to either discover and be grateful
for new opportunities that were unknown
in other words it didn't go according to
plan but i kind of like where it's going
or it didn't go according to plan i
don't like this but what can i learn
from this i'm grateful for the lesson
i'm grateful for the relationship i'm
grateful for something that happened and
i can always find at least one thing
i'll share a story so i have an
uncomfortable relationship with this one
person in my life who's who's been in my
life professionally we're not friends we
have a professional relationship
and i don't trust him at all and i've
struggled many times because i felt used
i've suffered unbelievable anger towards
this person
and i've attempted to reform them and
one of the ways i attempted to do it was
by taking responsibility for my part of
the broken relationship and so i called
him up and said let's meet for lunch
and we sat down and i said i'm sorry i
didn't ask for anything in return i just
said i'm sorry
and i went through the things that i'm
sorry for like being reactive being
inappropriate you know whatever whatever
it was
and he just sat there he didn't even
acknowledge he didn't say thank you just
sort of nodded as if this is about time
and i realized i'm not reforming
anything here this relationship is so
broken the only way i got over that
because it was like
everybody knew not to bring up his name
because i would go off the handle right
it was like such a trigger
and
where i learned to put that anger aside
where his name was no longer a trigger
was when i started to ask myself what am
i grateful for from that relationship
and i am grateful that i went on the
journey to learn how to take
accountability for my
part
even
if i didn't think that the other person
was going to
i learned a skill set that i did not
have because of that situation
i'm grateful also
that i can accept someone's nature
and not try to change it
well i think that acceptance is like one
of the most powerful
sort of pieces of it one of my favorite
quotes is leo tolstoy everyone thinks
about changing the world no one thinks
about changing themselves yeah
and that then
how do we reorient when it's like okay
all i can do is actually control myself
this is where gratitude like how do we
trigger our positive emotions that we
don't become triggered by our negative
ones and it's not that we don't feel the
negative ones
it's just how do we not become triggered
by them like anger just anger is a is a
good feeling to acknowledge
petty anger not so good it's not that
you those challenging moments don't go
away it's just how what is your
relationship to them now
we have to talk about how triggered we
all are by each other
whether it's vax versus novak's mask
versus no mask left versus right or you
know this president versus that
president somebody merely uttering their
point of view
can literally send somebody else into a
tailspin and by the way i see it on both
sides of the political equation and
intolerance that you simply acknowledge
somebody's point of view on the other
side and literally can
send somebody into a rage like me and
that that guy in my career like it's
such a trigger
and to say to oneself
what am i grateful for to look inwards i
i hear this with psychology students you
know i love asking people who major in
psychology why did you choose to major
in psychology and
almost universally the answer is well i
want to understand other people so that
i can understand myself and what i've
learned in my in my entire career is
it's the exact opposite
which is the more you can understand
yourself the more you can understand
other people
and that practice of gratitude
to go inwards to what you said which is
everybody wants to change the world but
nobody wants to change themselves
we're in a young generation that's very
activist very wants to change the world
which i admire and adore
to change the world we must
have to
say to ourselves well what work am i
willing to do on me
so that i can change the world change my
family change my community find peace
and love and the neuroscience supports
that part of
changing your
sort of emotions and feelings is your
physiology and your physiology is often
being driven by your environment and so
how you relate to your environment and
whether you're like meditation and
breathing
helps settle the body and so i like some
of the more interesting work right now i
find is actually in embodiment work
which is how is your body physically
reacting your body's in some ways like
this giant algorithm that's constantly
processing information
and if
your body is on high alert then how you
process your environment is going to be
very reactive and so
thinking about our relationship of like
how are we giving thanks how are we
connecting to people how are we being
present to them that's actually about us
not them there's an irony in this isn't
there and for those who listen to my
work and know my work i say this a lot
which is there's an entire section in
the bookshop called self-help and
there's no section on the bookshop
called help others and what we need is a
help others industry
and the great irony
in being a better servant to others and
for others is that we have to be willing
to take on ourselves we're part of a
relationship we are a puzzle piece but
we are only one puzzle piece
to know our shape and know what piece of
the puzzle we are and to be the best
puzzle piece we can be
makes us connect with others a lot
better gratitude helps us actually
change the pace at which we adapt to
change and if we can adapt to change
faster then we can be more present
if we're slow to adapting to change then
we're actually like holding on to
something past or reacting to what's
coming at us and we're not being present
to what just is for anyone who has not
practiced
gratitude as a practice you know it's
not like saying thank you for the
birthday present
the thing that i find magical about it
is
it's can be very very small
you know somebody asked me recently how
is it that i'm always so happy
and the answer is because i find joy in
little things
i don't need big things to make me smile
seeing a hummingbird outside my window
like i really like that i think they're
so cool or the rumble of a beautiful
sounding engine
you know because i'm a bit of a gear
head you know
like those little things i just i
acknowledge them i say oh god that's
such a nice sound to look at that bird
isn't isn't it pretty or a color or a
sound or a
sentence and i think that's part of what
gratitude is which is when you say you
have a daily gratitude practice you're
like well i don't have that much stuff
in my life to be grateful for in a daily
basis
we're thinking too big what i would say
it's not you're not actually
appreciating small things what you're
appreciating is specific things oh i
like that distinction and when you
appreciate specific things then you're
actually really being able to sort of
see it
unto itself and so this actually came up
in the last gratitude class
was the story of
walking home with my youngest daughter
and she was telling me she's like dad
i'm really grateful for this sidewalk
and i was like you're grateful for why
are you grateful for the sidewalk and
she says well if we didn't have the
sidewalk it means we would be walking in
the street
and that would be very unsafe and so
by having the sidewalk we can walk home
safely and you know and it brought up
this poem that
i remember this specific line that
sidewalks are where errands and
epiphanies can happen
and so when we can appreciate the
mundane and the miraculous and just sort
of be open to all of it
that's when we're actually noticing the
world as it is not as we want it to be
or as it should be or you know what it
could be
just this is the world as it is and
gratitude is just sort of like how do we
actually just sort of see the world as
it is how do we just notice what is
there
and appreciate it when we talk about
reconnecting with people who trigger us
or we disagree with and the thanksgiving
table
politics has entered the thanksgiving
table
you know for so many they struggle to
sit down with that uncle or that aunt
that has different views to them for
fear of somebody getting triggered and
sort of there are these deals that are
made we just won't bring it up
so avoidance is one strategy for sure
but i think what you're talking about is
we can find and i'm going to use the
word specific instead of small because i
really like the distinction find
something specific to be grateful for
in anything and everything that happens
for your daughter she found safety in
the sidewalk with her dad which is my
goodness so beautiful and poetic that
level of specificity
to be specific about the thing we're
grateful for that thing can be shared
that thing can be talked about and help
someone else see the world in a
different way so now we're getting into
the help others industry right
so
one of my favorite things to do is tell
my friends the things that i'm grateful
for in our friendships i can't help it
it comes out all the time
and it reinforces these friendships over
and over again i have a friend who she
and i have very very very different
political points of view
where we represent the polar opposites
of america
and yet she's one of my dearest and best
friends in the world and one of the
things that we have found that helps us
listen to each other
is that we regularly tell each other
what we're grateful for from each other
and that creates safe space for us to
have difficult conversations because we
have already acknowledged and built a
very strong foundation for all the
things we really really are grateful for
in each other so it's not that we've
avoided having difficult conversations
it's that we show up for those difficult
conversations with deep love respect and
gratitude for the other and what i hear
you saying also is that you're willing
to
listen right to hear and be heard to see
and be seen and this is i think one of
the fundamental challenges is that when
we have disagreement we make the other
person feel invisible right and then
because the other person then feels
invisible
then they're like gonna shout out or
they're gonna like go away what you're
doing is sort of showing that like hey i
see you hey i hear you
uh and that's what gratitude is is an
acknowledgement as opposed to just sort
of taking those things for granted and
it goes in a very uncomfortable
direction for some
and i learned this from dia khan the
bafta and emmy award-winning
documentarian
where she said we all have this desire
to feel
seen and feel understood and feel heard
and unfortunately you're going to
struggle to find those feelings unless
you're willing
to show them to another first what i
appreciate you saying is you're
acknowledging other people's feelings
and emotions and it's hard to do that if
you can't even do that for yourself
right like if you can't even sort of
acknowledge
not just the joy but the pain
the anger
you know the full suite of emotions that
we have
if you can't even acknowledge that for
yourself it's gonna be really hard to
acknowledge in other people and we
become self-righteous about it right
well they should go first
they should listen to me i'm the one
who's not heard i'm the one who's not
understood and we don't just see this
play out in big political discussions
but we see this play out at work between
employees and employers we can create
victims out of ourselves
what have they done to me and it goes
both ways it just plays to that theme
that we are not in any of this alone
like we don't go through career alone we
don't go through life alone you can't go
through relationships alone you can't
even walk down the street alone at some
point whether you like it or not you're
gonna have to interact with people
sometimes substantively and sometimes
innocuously but you're gonna have to do
it so expecting the world to fawn or
fall over to make us feel seen heard
understood happy safe grateful
it's an impossible standard
and that goes back to that psychology
misunderstanding the better i can
understand myself the better i can learn
to make others feel seen heard
understood the better they will be
equipped to make me feel the same
and this is what the help others
industry is all about the hub others
industry isn't about martyrdom it's not
about this excessive amount of giving to
the point of self-pain
that's not what this is the whole point
of the help others industry is
initiative
that's it right
that i will choose to go first that's
all it is
i will acknowledge another because i
want to be acknowledged i will hear
another because i want to be heard i
will forgive another because i want to
be forgiven
this is why giving is receiving
and this is why giving is receiving i
mean it's so corny right yeah and this
is what i think is important about your
work
is you're spiritual-ish in the way you
talk about this stuff
that's perfect yes
you know
you're spiritual-ish in the way you talk
about it so it's not alienating to those
who find this stuff deeply spiritual but
at the same time it's not alienating to
those who find this stuff non-spiritual
right and i think that's really
important which is
you are a spokesperson to the people who
need to hear this not to the people
who've already heard it well i think
this is what's so powerful about
the people who resonate with you is
how do you speak to early adopters right
like who wants to sort of see the change
is ready for the change and you and
you're not going to necessarily reach
everyone at first you're referring to
the law of diffusion of innovation the
theory put forward i think in the 60s by
emirate rogers
basically to all populations sift across
the standing deviation the old bell
curve if you have high performance in
the population you have low performers
regardless of the size of the population
the first two and a half percent are
your innovators the big idea people
you're steve jobs your elon musks
the next thirteen and a half percent are
your early adopters
then you have your early majority or
late majority in the laggards and the
whole point is if you want to have a
quote-unquote impact on the world you
actually don't go after the world
you don't go after the majority
you go and find those early adopters the
ones who are a little more open-minded a
little more open to taking a risk a
little more open to giving it a shot
whereas the majority wants a guarantee
what'll i get if it goes wrong will will
i get in trouble will you take the blame
will you pay me back if it doesn't work
out an early adopter mentality is just
higher risk tolerance and by the way
we're all early adopters in various
places it's not a fixed thing
i'm a laggard when it comes to fashion
[Music]
i am not an early adopter and for change
to happen it's to find those who are
willing to make the change and
eventually it catches on and this is
what the law of diffusion is all about
it's about creating tipping points
you know there was a time where we used
to talk about world peace pretty openly
and now it sounds like weird
i think we miss that i think we miss
idealism
in our nation
idealism seems to have gone by the
wayside and like practicality
everything's practical everything's
algorithmic everything's metrics metrics
metrics measure measure measure what
gets measured gets done it's like well
you know how do you measure the hug from
a mother
to their child how do you measure that
that should be done we're not measuring
it kind of important you know not
everything
has a metric but we know that these
things are important i think that's
reconnecting with these things and this
goes back to your point of the unknown
and the fearlessness which is i'm going
to do this thing because it's the right
thing to do even though
i don't know exactly right now but i'll
find out later and then i'll be grateful
for it
well that's yeah that's dealing with
those fears and what is scary yeah i get
a kick out of technology you know how
reliant we are on such imperfect
technology in this modern world you know
our cell phones are constantly dropping
signals and zoom is constantly freezing
and you know this stuff mostly works
right but it's unbelievable how broken
it is and yet we're perfectly fine with
all the broken and imperfections but
when it comes to people we expect
perfection
well yeah i mean that's the right we
expect everybody else to be more patient
to be more kind and and what does it
look like for us to actually do it i
have a last line of questioning how old
are you
47 so we're about the same age
i'd like to know something you're
grateful for for every decade of your
life zero to ten what are you grateful
for
so zero to ten
i
was born in san francisco and
moved to saudi arabia when i was six
months old and
i went around the world twice by the
time i was three even though i don't
remember any of that
what i appreciate was that i sort of had
an immediate sense early on in my life
of like we live
in a global society 10 to 20.
10 to 20 i moved to
los angeles it was the 1984 summer
olympics it was sam the eagle and
there was just a sense of
moving from
a
rural community in the pacific northwest
to the big city of la
it was a sense of awe
at the same time i'll just say that you
know i was in l.a in 92 with the civil
unrest and seeing my city sort of burn
down
and not being able to see the end of my
block because there was so much smoke in
the street and
i learned early on that democracy is
fragile and cities are fragile and so to
not take them for granted 20 to 30.
i think 20s to 30s
was learning that i could actually build
things and getting sort of a sense that
that idea of wanting to build the world
that i wanted to live in that i could
actually do it and so beginning to be in
real estate and like actually physically
building things that i could contribute
and make a mark was pretty exciting 30
to 40. that is definitely
kids kids kids um there would be no
gratitude practice but for having kids
and learning that they move at their own
speed and
i can either learn to adapt or be
unhappy and so
i was like okay
my heart is going to have to become
bigger if i want to be the parent that i
want to be and so yeah i would say my
wife uh who having an incredible partner
and then
having two kids that really are teaching
me how to be a better human
40 to now i think moving from just
building things to now building
companies
and
really being able to
how do you
not just do the work but create the
conditions for the things that you want
to see happen and be in collaboration
with other people i think the other sort
of piece that i'm starting to really
begin to appreciate is just my own
creativity and art so it's not just sort
of like a business mindset or
social good but
what does it mean to
tap into
more creative energy i'm becoming more
and more firmly
believing in the power of metaphor
and so that sort of long horizon that's
in front of us
what are we picturing that's there
and how do we actually sort of move
towards that or it move towards us and
what is that metaphor in our life that
we're going to be connected to so your
gratitude journey
in decades
is gratitude for the world and
appreciation for the fact that there's
more than one point of view a sense of
awe that came
and in that awe a sense of all of that
is great and big is also incredibly
fragile
there is the ability to build the world
you want to build in this fragile world
coming right down to your family that
you have a choice to build in how you
build a that it is just as fragile as
everything else and there's a
responsibility that then moves into a
sense of rebuilding and creativity
and this gratitude journey that you've
been on since the day you were born
is this relationship of big and fragile
and responsibility in those things that
we can do big things and the world is
big
but my goodness we each have a
responsibility to hold it up otherwise
things will break whether it's society
at large the world at large or just how
our family our family dynamics that we
have a role to play and we have to be
creative and all of that i i have to
bring you back in a few years so that we
can talk about the next decade
what a gift you just gave me in
reflecting back what i said and i feel
heard thank you and
and i think part of
what this next decade is about is us not
just creating but how do we co-create
i think that's in many ways the platform
that you are helping to create and
unleash is like it's not just about one
person but it's about many people and
how do we actually all sort of pull
together omar you are as magical now as
the moment i first talked to you
and i never do this i never use this as
a platform to plug
but
if you're interested in omar's work
please go check it out because
you'll be grateful
uh whether you want to go check out his
stuff
on his website which is in the link
below
or if you want to check out the course
he teaches on our platform you can check
that out i think we need we need a
little more gratitude in this world
um
you know my temptation is to say a lot
but it really is a little
it's specific
it's specific you know we need a
specific amount of gratitude in this
world
[Music]
omar thank you so much truly
thank you so so much
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other
[Music]
you